- She took a picture of a piece
of poop and sent it to me.
- (laughs)
- Like, that's what happens
when you are married with kids.
That's real life right there.
(relaxing music)
- I had three pregnancy tests
on the table when he entered,
and I was like, "If he sees it,
that's perfect. I don't
have to do anything."
- I didn't see it.
- And he didn't see it.
- I can't believe this is real sometimes.
- (laughs)
I know.
Once a day,
I feel like we look at each
other and we're like, "Man.
We're parents.
Weird, right?"
- What?
- Before you have kids,
you look at kids as like,
oh, what a funny little,
slightly dirty thing.
Go back to mommy.
And then, when you have kids,
I mean nothing's off-limits.
She loves to do a pterodactyl screech,
I'll screech right with her.
Yeah, when we're walking down
the street, we look odd going
(screeches)
But, like, we're connecting.
It's fun for us.
- Sometimes it's disgusting.
I mean she has a giant blow-out,
and you're just so proud of her.
You're like, "God, she's
gotta feel good right now."
- One thing for sure that I
didn't think I was gonna do
was have that cutesy dialogue.
"How's mamma's baby?"
And I have this,
I didn't even know my
voice could go that high.
Times done changed.
(pop music)
- Pretty much everything I do now
is something I said I wouldn't
do before I was pregnant.
- Now that I've become a dad,
- Oh.
- I've been falling asleep on
the spot, like, outta nowhere.
It's time to go to (laughs)
- Yeah, the other night,
he was asleep like this.
- There's a lot of changes for me.
I was an inconsiderate woman before.
I'm nicer, you know,
I talk to people more.
You're raising someone who's looking
at your every single move.
(uplifting music)
- I love it when Brooklyn smiles for sure.
- When Flynn stretches.
- Her arms are like this.
- (laughs)
That's as far as she can go.
- She has, like,
these monster stretches. They're so cute.
- I love it when London laughs.
- (laughs)
- Gives me open mouth kisses.
- I love it...
- Ahhhh.
- No, no, no.
With all the slobber.
- She said, "mamma."
So, I get out the camera, and I'm like,
"I'm gonna show off
what a great mom I am."
Who's this?
Mamma?
- (hiccups)
- Oh.
That's what you get when
you try to show off.
(uplifting guitar music)
- There's that aspect of wanting
to pass on everything that you know.
I also look forward to
experiencing things with her
that I've never experienced before.
- I can't wait to teach
her about stupid things
like gravity and
- (laughs)
- time dilation.
- I remember when I first came
out, my dad's main sadness,
I think, about it was that
he really wanted to see
what kind of dad I would be. And then...
And then, now we can.
- I would much rather be
single and a kick-ass mom
than be miserable in a relationship.
- I wanna go visit my pregnant self
and be like, "don't panic."
- Thanks, Flynn, for making me
forget about my to-do lists.
- I look forward to that
moment of walking in the door
and seeing you just smile
and have that huge grin on your face.
- It has been truly
incredible to be your mother
and I love every single day of it.
- Yeah! Good girl, good girl!
- I know you're gonna
be one of the good ones.
I know you're gonna make
the world a better place.
- You have changed my entire life.
- Changed my outlook on love.
- All for the better.
- I hope that I can make a
difference in your life like
my dad has in mine, and
just be there for you.
- Thank you for making my life worth it.
- You're my heartbeat.
- I never thought
that I'd poop holding onto someone else.